cyber security is more important than
ever as cyber attacks are on the rise
and our society becomes increasingly
connected according to a report by IBM
the number of cyber attacks has grown by
16% in the last year alone causing a
Global Financial impact of over $450
billion this has led to a growing demand
for trained cyber Security Professionals
with the global cyber security job
market that is expected to reach $247
billion by 2025 so why should you learn
cyber security in 2024 in this video we
will explore the top 10 reasons why this
field is so exciting and important and
if you're an aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learn postgraduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice that is designed to
accommodate a diverse range of Learners
and this course requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% average and
no prior programming experience and 1
plusus years of work experience is
preferred for more details use the link
mentioned in the description box below
and the link will navigate you to the
course page so without further Ado let's
get
started and our first reason is rising
cyber threat landscape so the
Contemporary digital era is witnessing
an alarming escalation in cyber threats
making it imperative to learn cyber
security the threat landscape is
evolving with unprecedented
sophistication encompassing a was AR
malicious activities from ransomware
attacks that hold organizations Hostage
to fishing schemes that Target
individuals the risk are diverse and
omnipresent cyber criminals exploit
vulnerabilities in software networks and
human behavior to compromise sensitive
data disrupt operations and cause
Financial losses nation state actors
engage in cyber Espionage posing
significant National Security risk as
businesses and governments in
increasingly digitize their operations
the potential for cyber threats
amplifies underscoring the critical need
for cyber security education and skills
and learning cyber security equips
individuals to comprehend these threats
develop preventive measures and
effectively respond to attacks
safeguarding digital assets and ensuring
a secure online environment for all so
this is the first reason for what you
should learn cyber security in 2024 and
now moving on to the second reason
that is job opportunities across
Industries so equipping oneself with
cyber security expertise offers
unparalleled opportunities across
diverse Industries such as Government
Finance Commerce education and healthare
these sectors are increasingly
recognizing the critical need to
safeguard their digital assets and
sensitive information professionals
skilled in cyber security are in high
demand to fortify defenses against cyber
threats and protect valuable data the
evolving technological landscape and the
growing frequency and sophistication of
cyber attacks underscore the importance
of individuals with the knowledge and
competence to prevent detect and
mitigate these threats by investing in
learning cyber security you position
yourself to tap into an expensive job
market and make a meaningful
contribution to safeguarding vital
interest in the modern digital age so
this is the second reason that is job
opportunity across Industries you have
so many Industries to work on and now
moving on to the third reason that is
cyber security skills
shortage so in today's digital driven
world the demand for cyber Security
Professionals far exceeds the current
Supply creating a concerning skills
shortage as technology rapidly advances
and cyber threats become more
sophisticated there's an urgent need to
bridge this Gap in expertise
organizations worldwide are are
grappling with the challenge of finding
qualified individuals capable of
Defending against a diverse side of
cyber attacks this shortage not only
highlights the criticality of cyber
security but also presents a compelling
reason to pursue a career or education
in this field understanding the severity
of the cyber security skill shortage
underscores significance of preparing
the next generation of professionals by
acquiring the necessary skills and
knowledge in cyber security individuals
can actively contribute to narrowing
this Gap fortifying digital defenses and
safeguarding sensitive information
against malicious actors moreover
entering the cyber security realm offers
promising career prospects and the
opportunity to make a meaningful impact
in an increasingly interconnected world
so this is also a main reason to learn
cyber security in 2024 now moving on to
the next reason and the reason is
financial rewards that is unlocking
prosperity in cyber security embarking
working on a journey to learn cyber
security opens doors to substantial
Financial rewards and long-term
Financial Security as the digital
landscape expands and cyber threats
multiply businesses are increasingly
willing to invest in skilled cyber
Security Professionals making this field
financially lucrative the demand for
cyber Security Experts far outweighs the
supply resulting in competitive salaries
bonuses and enticing benefits cyber
Security Professionals often enjoy
higher than average pay scales
reflective of the critical role they
play in safeguarding sensitive
information and ensuring the operational
Integrity of organizations entry-level
positions in cyber security often offer
impressive salaries and with experience
and experties professionals can climb
the career ladder swiftly commanding
even more substantial compensation
packages Additionally the global reach
of the internet means that cyber
security skills are in demand not only
locally but also internationally this
open up opportunities for lucrative
positions and even entrepreneurial
Ventures learning cyber security can
pave the way to a financially rewarding
and prosperous future providing a strong
incentive for individuals to pursue
expertise in this critical field and now
moving on to the fifth reason that is
mathematics is not a concern in cyber
security
learning so many prospective Learners
hesitate to pursue cyber security due to
a perceived requirement for advanced
mathematical skills however it's
essential to dispel this myth while a
foundational understanding of
mathematics is helpful particularly in
areas like encryption and algorithms
Advanced mathematical progress is not a
prerequisite for mastering cyber
security modern cyber security courses
and training programs are designed to C
to a wide range of Learners including
those with weing mathematical aptitudes
cyber security primarily for focuses on
principles of security protocols
networking risk management and ethical
hacking these areas require logical and
critical thinking rather than intricate
mathematical calculations Concepts like
threat detection vulnerability
assessment and security policy
implementation involve logic and problem
solving abilities more than complex
mathematical equations moreover
specialized tools and software automate
many mathematical aspects allowing
professionals to FOC focus on applying
cyber security principles effectively in
Ence while a basic understanding of
mathematics is beneficial it should not
deter anyone from embarking on a journey
to learn and Excel in the dynamic and
crucial field of cyber security and now
I have an inside for you guys that is if
you are an aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply L
Advanced executive program in cyber
security in collaboration with npci
should be your right choice with this
program you can transform your career in
6 months for India specific region only
this course provides a high engagement
learning experience with real world
applications and is designed for
individuals who want to start a new more
fulfilling career and now moving back to
our reasons to learn cyber security in
2024 so now we'll see the sixth reason
that is protecting personal
data in an era dominated by technology
and
interconnectedness safeguarding personal
data is Paramount learning cyber
security equips individuals with the
Knowledge and Skills necessary to Shield
their digital identities from malicious
actors cyber criminals relentlessly
Target personal information ranging from
financial data to login credentials for
various illicit activities by
understanding cyber security principles
individuals can construct robust
defenses around their online presence
mitigating the risk of identifying theft
financial fraud and privacy breaches
understanding encryption secure browsing
habits and implementing multiactor
authentication are just a few aspects of
cyber security that bolster personal
data protection learning to discern
fishing attempts and secure online
transactions add another layer of
security ensuring us safer digital
experience ultimately acquiring
expertise in cyber security EMP Parts
individuals to take control of their
data enhancing their digital resilience
and fostering a more secure online
environment for everyone so this was
about protecting personal data so you
can learn cyber security for your
personal reasons also so you can be
aware of the new advancement error that
is coming up and now moving on to the
seventh reason that is securing
businesses
safeguarding the digital foundation so
in an era where businesses operate
within a was digital ecosystem
safeguarding their valuable assets and
sensitive information is Paramount cyber
security stands as the sen cyber
security stands as the Sentinel guarding
this digital RM making it a critical
discipline to learn and master learning
cyber security equips individuals with
expertise to design Implement and
maintain robust security measures
tailored to diverse organizational needs
by acquiring skills in network security
encryption threat detection and incident
response individuals can effectively
Shield businesses from malicious attacks
and unauthorized access a well-protected
business not only mitigates financial
risk associated with data breaches but
also upholds its reputation and customer
trust cyber security knowledge empowers
professionals to anticipate and th cyber
threats ensuring business continuity and
fostering a secure environment for
Innovation and growth ultimately
investing in cyber security education is
an investment in the longivity and
resilience of businesses in the digital
age so this was about securing
businesses and the reason to learn cyber
security Now moving on to the eighth
reason that is work with Top Class
organizations that is if you have the
cyber security skills you can work with
Top Class organizations so learning
cyber security opens the doors to
partnering with Top Class organizations
and a compelling reason to embark on
this career path in today's digital age
corporations government agencies even
defense agencies financial institutions
Healthcare organizations and Technology
joints are all acutely aware of all
critical importance of safeguarding
their digital assets and sensitive data
some of the well-known organizations
such as Dell enture Etc have many cyber
Security Professionals working for them
at many top positions and by acquiring
expertise in cyber security you position
yourself to work with industry-leading
entities renowned for their commitment
to digital security these organizations
offer unparalled opportunities to apply
your skills at a grand scale developing
and implementing Cutting Edge security
measures working alongside Professionals
in these environments not only enriches
your understanding of cyber security in
cases but also provides a platform for
career growth and exposure to Advanced
Technology
the impact of your efforts in securing
vital systems and data for such
reputable organizations can be both
professionally gratifying and globally
significant so this is also one of the
main reason to work with Top Class
organizations and to learn cyber
security to work with them now moving on
to the ninth reason that is global cyber
security Trends Trends may come and go
but cyber security Trends Are Forever
The Paramount reason to Del into cyber
security is its enduring relevance amids
evolving Trends in the tech landscape
unlike many it domains affected by
frequent technological shifts impacting
job availability and earnings cyber
security stands resilient the realm of
cyber security post immense and enduring
demand expected to persist given the
rapid expansion of the internet over the
past few years little has changed in
this sector affording cyber Security
Experts a wide area of career
opportunities on meeting requisite
qualifications cyber security job
prospect remain consistently high with
no foreseeable dip in demand for
professionals who have undergone
specialized training in this field
another compelling incentive for young
individuals to pursue cyber security is
the wealth of knowledge it offers making
it a promising career path for newcomers
in addition staying a breast of evolving
threats is crucial given the escalating
sophistication of cyber attacks so this
was about the ninth reason that is
global cyber security Trends now moving
on to the 10th reason that is unlimited
career growth options embarking on a
journey to learn cyber security opens
doors to a realm of unlimited career
growth opportunities the digital age has
elevated the significance of cyber
security making it an indispensable
component of every organization's
operations as cyber threats evolve in
complexity and frequency the demand for
cyber Security Professionals continues
to Skyrocket acquiring expertise in this
field presents a vast area of career
paths from ethical hacking and
penetration testing to security analysis
incident response and risk management
the versatility of cyber security skills
allows professionals to explore various
sectors such as Finance Healthcare
government and Technology offering
diverse work environments and challenges
with the global shortage of skilled
cyber Security Experts individuals with
the right knowledge and proficiency are
highly sought after ensuring a
continuous and flux of job offers and
competitive salaries the dynamic nature
of the field ensures that those who
invest in cyber security Education and
Training will find themselves in a
Perpetual cycle of growth both
personally and professionally as they
strive to protect the digital world so
this was all about the 10 reasons to
learn cyber security in
2024 and this was all for this tutorial
and I hope you guys found it informative
and helpful and now let's take a minute
to hear from our Learners who have EXP
experienced massive success in their
careers by opening out to Simply learn
courses hi I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old
and last year I upskilled with simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
it sector and various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course course I must
say was packed with practical examples
it was led by highly skilled certif
certified instructors I worked with many
companies before as a security analyst
and architect on a contract basis but I
needed some stability which I got with
the job I just started with infosis as a
cyber security consultant happened after
I took the course but first and foremost
I've been a learner be a learner first
and if you like this session then like
share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here